from calorie count to portion sizes we
wanted to find out all the differences
between Five Guys in Italy and the US
this is food
boes burgers in Italy come in two sizes
little and regular little has one paty
and regular has two our Burgers also
come in two sizes little and regular
let's weigh a regular plain hamburger in
both countries to see who has the bigger
Burgers that's uh 136 G 138 G the burger
mark is really off-putting any
difference might be down to the patties
Five Guys actually tells us that the US
Patty should weigh about 94 G each or
3.3 o although this will be the weight
before cooking the five gu Italy website
says that the patties when uncooked
should weigh 67 G so we're going to see
if that's true obviously this have been
cooked so the meat should have released
some fat but
we're going to find out soon this is a
Five Guys Hot Dog it looks a little
weird because they slice them down the
middle to cook them I really love how
these cook when they're sliced let's
measure the length first that's about
16.2 CM think that's about 15 cm yeah 6
in we don't use inches in it now let's
weigh the plain hot dog that is 144 G
we're now going to weigh it so just for
reference we put mustard ketchup and
onions in this soft dog so obviously
it's going to be B heavier than a
regular one let's see 195 G our fries
come in three sizes in either plain or
cajun spice you can get little regular
or large our Five Guys fries come in
three sizes either plain or with Kajun
spice little regular and large according
to Five Guys the little should weigh 227
G let's see if that's true it's not it's
82 G this is 82 oh
wait yeah it's 82 G our little fries
should weigh 256 G 103 G so we did ask a
Five Guys employee about how they
package their fries they scoop the fries
into one of these cups put that in the
bag and then they do another scoop of
fries on top I think so that could be
the reason why some of these weights are
off there's just just like fries
everywhere don't really know which fry
came from which cup it's a mess we're
supposed to have
1,225 G Al together but right now we're
sitting at 870 G including the extra
fries which aren't really extra so our
total should have been 1,220 G but we
got 580 G so that's less than half
milkshakes in Italy come in one size and
this is supposed to be 400 ml so this is
the vanilla milk milkshake in the US I
believe we only have one size of
milkshake so let's see how much we get
it's actually almost 500 I'll say it's
like
ml something around
that here's everything you'll find at
Five Guys in the US that you won't find
in Italy here's everything you find at
Five Guys Italy that you won't find in
the US the owners of Five Guys like to
keep the restaurants and the menus all
the same so there aren't any exclusive
Burger options in the US this is the
Five Guys burger menu so our Burger
menus are almost exactly the same the
only difference is that here you can
order two additional patties not just
one uh so you end up with a burger with
four patties in it I'm not sure you can
do that in the US maybe if you ask
nicely but it's an official feature here
since Five Guys is known for its
customizable options you probably could
order two extra patties for your burger
but we'll let you have this one cl a but
seeing as America doesn't have official
exclusive menu items Five Guys
enthusiasts had to get creative and make
their own in the form of an unofficial
secret menu so this is the patty melt
it's a grilled cheese sandwich with an
extra Patty inside it looks kind of good
to me I love when restaurants do grilled
cheeses with the Buns of the burgers I
think it tastes so
good I feel like I like this better than
the Five Guys Burgers it's something
about the way the bread gets all toasty
just makes it so much more delicious so
next is the artery Annihilator that's a
little ridiculous so we have to put a
bacon hot dog inside of a bacon
cheeseburger how I'm going to do that I
don't know what I think is right is
making it edible in some form so I'm
just going to like break it up a
little I'm trying to squish it down cuz
it's not going to fit into my mouth
okay
this literally sucks like don't order
this there's no reason for you if you
want a hot dog and a burger a
burger let me swallow this stupid bite
of food hold on I feel like putting the
hot dog into the burger doesn't make it
taste any better it just makes it a lot
harder to eat and a lot less enjoyable
of an experience so I think this is
really not fun or good to me I think
this should be at the top so let's try
double bread yeah there's a bit of s
right so here's your Italian version
artery Annihilator right I don't know I
feel like this is annihilating my
eyesight as well on top of my arteries
if I were to try
[Music]
it too much stuff Five Guys is of course
famous for its wide selection of Free
Toppings according to Five Guys there
are over 250,000 th ways to customize
your burger now these aren't exclusive
toppings but here's what you can get the
only exclusive topping we have in
America is A1 Sauce in Italy the
toppings are almost exactly the same as
in the us but we do have one exclusive
sauce which is the HP Sauce according to
chefs at 5 Guys when customizing your
burger there's a specific way it has to
be stacked within their rules it should
be the bottom bun then any wet items
like grilled onions or mushrooms then
the first Patty two slices of cheese
then another Patty then dry items like
lettuce tomatoes and jalapenos go on top
and then there's the top bun to finish
it all off let's see if it came in the
order that it's supposed to come in so
at the bottom I see the grilled onions I
see grilled mushrooms and I also see
peppers green peppers so it's already
out of order because the jalapenos are
on the bottom for some reason I feel
like I don't know I feel like this if it
doesn't affect the taste I personally do
not care but if it's their law in the
Five Guys then I guess you should be
doing it I don't know all right so we
got the first Patty the two slices of
cheese another Patty and then on top we
have the lettuce and tomatoes let's
check if the order is the same here in
Italy so yes we got bottom bun onions
and mushrooms we got a Patti cheese we
got another
Patty tomatoes and lettuce at the top
good job Five Guys Five Guys also offers
sandwich options there aren't any
exclusive sandwiches in the US but
here's what you can get so we have a
grilled cheese a BLT and a veggie
sandwich veggie
sandwich it's not bad it's just a little
too vegetable heavy for me
no next is the BLT which if you mess
this
up yeah it tastes like an okay BLT it
just mostly tastes like bacon and then
we have the grilled cheese which I think
will be good because I already liked the
patty melt and they're like
sisters that's a really good grilled
cheese we do have one exclusive in Italy
which is a be te sandwich with cheese
which it's supposed to be this one uh
but uh there's been a bit of a mixup in
the order um and the one we got has just
cheese and a lot of bacon there aren't
any exclusive Five Guys Hot Dog options
in either country but here's you can get
a hot dog a bacon dog a cheese dog or a
bacon cheese dog I've never had a hot
dog with cheese on it so I am kind of
intrigued I will say though I am a fan
of the slicing the hot dog and putting
like this side on the griddles just so
everything gets nice and crispy I think
they do taste better that
way it's not for me something about the
cheese and the hot dog mixing together
feels wrong cuz i' I I've never had it
it feels weird so so this is the uh
bacon and cheese hot dog looks pretty
good to me but I'm not I'm not really
familiar with hot dogs I think in
general in Italy we don't really have
that many like definitely burgers are
more
popular yeah maybe with some sa it'll be
a bit better in the US we have two
exclusive milkshake options the Oreo
creme and the double stuff which I am
very excited about I love Oreos and Oreo
milkshakes are objectively the best
milkshake let's try the Oreo creme first
so this is just like the filling of the
Oreos essentially okay give it a good
swirl and it is creme and not
cream that is literally so good you're
actually drinking the creme inside of an
Oreo next is double stuff so I assume
this has the creme and also a bunch of
Oreo pieces in it oh my God this is the
best one at Five Guys you can actually
add bacon to any of their milkshake
flavors this is a vanilla bacon I just
feel like vanilla seemed like the
easiest thing to pair with the bacon
I've never tried this before but let's
see it tastes like vanilla and bacon I'm
just trying to decide mentally if that's
like something I should have eaten we
thought we had one exclusives in the
milkshake Department in Italy on their
website it still states that there is a
coffee milkshake that you can order we
did order it but then we got um when we
got to the store to collect it turns out
it's been discontinued and it's been
years they haven't done it so please
update your website Five Guys we still
got a bacon milkshake and then weirdly
on the website also it lets you add
every single flavor so we got a
milkshake with absolutely everything
that was available what's in here there
is Oreos banana strawberry there's like
so many different things that just
in my mind they don't really work
together I think there's just too many
things to even make out what stuff is to
be honest it's not too bad now we've got
the bacon milkshake mix in bacon with
milk it's it does sound very ridiculous
like I'm a bit disappointed though cuz I
don't really taste the bacon much we
also have some drink options you can
only get in the US simply lemonade root
beer and Dr Pepper do Italians like root
beer that's what I would love to know
you know what that is I'm sure they do
if you're Italian from Italy comment
down below and tell me if you know what
rubber is one and two do you actually
think it's good because here people love
it and here are all the drinks that you
can only find in Italy we've got Fanta
orange sparkling water and then four
beers so let's talk about prices now in
Italy at Five Guys a cheeseburger will
cost you €1
1345 translated $ do that is
$14.82 so for comparison at McDonald's
you can get a cheeseburger for €2 so
yeah for the same price 13 something EUR
you could get six of these at the other
chain that's maybe too cheap but €13 for
a burger in team foil just sort of all
squished together still at a fast food
chain that's way way uh over what I
would pay in the US a cheeseburger will
cost cost you
$1.79 or
€1.7 that is a 26% decrease in price so
Five Guys is doing this thing where all
of their food is fresh and made to order
they're trying to kind of raise the
standard of what fast food could be I
think that's why their prices are on the
higher end although I don't know if
that's fully Justified because I can say
that I've had better cheaper Burgers I
think that's allowed and to make that a
meal so with a regular fries and a drink
that will cost you €23 20 which in
dollars is
$25 57 again so overpriced like3 for all
this and I still don't even have a plate
it's just a lot a lot to make it a meal
with regular fries and a regular drink
it will cost you
$21 47 or €1
1948 I it's just not making sense to me
$21 for a fast food Burger Friesen drink
no absolutely
not let's take a look at some of the
basic ingredients at Five Guys Italy in
Italy the burger itself is 100% ground
beef and in the US a burger actually
contains 8020 USDA ground chuck if you
want to add cheese to your burger though
here's everything that's in the cheese
Five Guys cheese in the US contains all
of these
ingredients let's look at the bun it
contains water salt sugar vegetable
shortening milk eggs bleached bread
flour yeast and sesame seeds so in Italy
the bun has a total of 11 ingredients
that's two more than the US the
additional ingredients are calcium
carbonate and spirit vinegar the only
difference in the hot dogs is some of
the ingredients to make the pink
coloring we love dying our food here the
ingredients for the fries are really
simple it's just potatoes refined peanut
oil and salt if you go to a Five Guys
they have this little board that tells
you where your potatoes are coming from
that day and ours came from St Anthony
Idaho and the fries at five guys are
very simple there are potatoes peanut
oil and salt it's the first thing that I
see something cooked with peanut oil
let's see do they taste like peanuts at
all or
actually they taste quite potato like
they taste quite nice yeah maybe it's
the peanut oil after
all in the US a cheeseburger that has a
bun two patties two pieces of cheese and
no toppings comes out to about 984
calories the total fat comes out to
about 55 G carbs 39 G sugar 8 G and
sodium
1,50 mg in Italy a regular cheeseburger
contains
756 calories of which 45 G are total fat
40 G are carbs 8 G are sugar and 98 mg
are sodium and if you make that a meal
you can add fries and uh they contain
1,22 calories then 66 G of fat 120 g of
carbs 1.7 g of sugar and and 716 mg of
sodium our regular fries are 953
calories 41 G of fat 131 G of carbs 4 g
of sugar and 962 mg of sodium and a
chocolate milkshake contains
874 calories then 39 G of
fat 121 G of carbs 108 g of sugar and 4
48 mg of sodium and a chocolate
milkshake is 830 calories 36 G of fat6 G
of carbs 107 g of sugar and 400 mg of
sodium so the total for a meal that
includes a cheeseburger regular fries
and the milkshake is
2752 calories of which 150 g are total
fat then 281 G carbs 118 G of sugar and
2,32 mg of sodium bringing the total to
2,767 calories 132 G of total fat 286 G
of carbs 119 g of sugar and
2,412 mg of sodium well the numbers for
the fries are actually based on what is
uh stated on the website and we got
basically half of what is stated there
so if you want to make this a little bit
more accurate you should have the uh
nutrition nutrition numbers as
well Five Guys first opened in Italy in
2018 in Milan just behind the dwo so a
very touristic uh location and then in
2021 after a bit of a coid break it
opened in Rome and there are now another
four locations in Milan I think well
starting with Milan it's a very smart
choice obviously uh it's the
most International City there's a lot of
tourists like fashion capital of Italy
uh a lot of offices uh a lot of
foreigners as well here which is maybe
the reason why they open here I know
Five Guys is available in a lot of
places but something about The Branding
and the way the food is presented feels
very East Coast to me I think it's
because the fries remind me of Boardwalk
fries that you'd get down at the Jersey
Shore it's a little weird because some
stuff has the Five Guys logo on it and
you can tell where it's from other stuff
like the fries and the burgers just come
in regular foil a regular unmarked cup
so it's like it's not a lot of brand
recognition at least for me I've never
even seen a Five Guys advertisement I've
never seen a commercial I've never
gotten an ad once you take like this cup
away you probably wouldn't know where I
got this food from because their burgers
are made to order it does take longer
for you to get your order I've waited
like at least 10 minutes for my order
out of five guys before so it's not like
the fastest fast food option but the
food is as fresh as it can be it kind of
gives me the feeling of food you'd get
at a concession stand at like a local
baseball game at a school or something
it's definitely got its own thing going
on here are all the ingredients in the
Five Guys buns in the Five Guys buns all
five of their buns Jesus okay